That
's so cute r The drill dots are made of cheese and the rich meat
sauce makes my heart pound.
So let's both low search Kato
I'd like to say yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes,
yes, yes, yes.
1 man 2 smooth rice pew 0 It
feels like cotton candy made so finely that it can't be a mysterious magic
com q 0 and meat sauce are beautiful Yes, it's
wonderful  I can't help
but be interested in the vivid movement of the green sauce.
Parmentier
One of the charms that won't come at night
[Music]
Ayla's strange place 3 Do it
[Music] Kobayashi
Nagura had a voice
Yes, the winning tube points to Judau's horse
.  Which one is
oh oh,
what's wrong with both teams admitting defeat?